bonjour gilbert collard merci beaucoup
d'alcool avec nous on dirait que ce
matin sur rtl france on va parler bien
sûr de l'actualité politique du moment à
commencer par la démission de la maire
de marseille hier michel ribes livre là
l'a annoncé il ya eu pas mal de
réactions on va regarder d'abord celle
du maire et l'ère des 9e et et du xviiie
et 10e arrondissements de marseille et
on en parle après il y avait des
bruissements depuis hier soir rumeur
confirmée dans la journée
c'est un scandale politique un hold up
avec cette histoire de switch elle
propose un petit arrangement entre amis
ce qui me semble très éloignée des
valeurs prônées pendant la campagne par
le printemps marseillais gilbert collard
votre réaction
un certain disent il faut de nouvelles
élections comment faut-il un remplacer
le maire de marseille selon vous pour
d'abord cette élection a été une
mascarade puisque se faire élire pour
démissionner quelques mois après c'est
se moquer du chiffrage populaire c'est
clair on a affaire à des gens qui
passent leur temps à parler d' honnêtes
et démocratiques et qui dès l'instant où
ils sont élus pour des raisons de
convenance personnelle et parce que
c'était un accord pré établis rend la
vie le maire ou la mairesse démission
c'est un mépris absolu évident du vote
pour que le nouveau maire soit ému il
faut que le conseil municipal se
réunissent et désigne le successeur il
ne pourrait y avoir de nouvelles
élections
hélas que si tout le conseil municipal
démissionne ce début d intérêt vu les
gamins dans lesquelles ils vont tous
grignoter ou voir même s'empiffrer a peu
de chances d'arriver mais là on touche à
quelque chose quand même
de très significatif la magouille
politique voilà là maintenant s'ils y
ait une entendent manoeuvre lalalala
maire de marseille actuel ne voulait pas
conserver cette place là voulaient même
pas je crois qu'elle est maintenant
directrice des hôpitaux de marseille en
sa qualité d league cela lui suffit pas
donc on a affaire à une
on a affaire une à une perversion du
système démocratique
et voilà que les crues que les électeurs
qui ont porté à la mairie un maire
écologiste supposé terre parce que bon
là encore il faudra voir ce que veut
dire écologistes et se retrouve mirap
avec la maire socialiste est pas beau ça
ça s'appelle de la prestidigitation
électorale ou ou de l'escroquerie au
suffrage autres titres de l'actualité
politique il ya cette annonce d'
emmanuel macron qui veut un référendum
pour inscrire le climat dans la
constitution française votre réaction
gilbert collard il se fout de la gueule
de la démocratie 7 sept
l'inscription de de la défense du climat
de l'écologie est inscrite dans le
préambule de la constitution qui fait
référence à la charte
pourquoi donc organiser ce référendum si
ce n'est tout simplement pour créer une
espèce de débat politique qui va lui
permettre de de de fédérer en vue des
présidentielles tous les écolos
de france se trompe parce que lorsqu'il
ya un référendum
l'électorat votre part souvent sur le
sujet ils votent sur la personne et là
il pourrait prendre un camouflet enfin
c'est quand même extraordinaire de 2,2
d'entendre un président de la république
nous dire qu'il va inscrire pour faire
ça l'écologie dans la constitution
alors que le la constitution dans son
préambule
depuis 2005 je crois met en évidence la
protection environnementale par
référence à une charte ce sera aux
français de décider
a priori non mais c'est déjà dans la
course type d'événement c'est tellement
énorme que même quand on le dit on ne
comprend pas c'est ça qui est sorti chez
chez makro la protection de
l'environnement dans sa totalité dans sa
globalité est déjà dans le préambule de
notre constitution
depuis 2005 c'est donc organiser un
référendum pour le bleu pour l'eau pour
les besoins d'une élection
présidentielle en essayant de piéger les
écologistes qui pourront pas dire non
qui sera obligé de dire oui et qui en
disant oui vont se rapprocher de macron
celle là encore c'est de la
prestidigitation politique c'est de la
manipulation
je crois qu'il faut il faudrait qu'il
faut arriver il faudrait que tout le
monde comprenne qu'on nous demande de
faire un référendum sur un sujet qu'il
utile puisque figurant déjà dans la
constitution
alors que quand même le vrai référendum
il devrait porter sur l'immigration sur
la question migratoire en france on va
parler de moi on va parler de la
question sécuritaire à présent on l'a vu
à nantes hier il y a eu encore de
nouvelles manifestations contre la loi
dite de sécurité globale il ya eu aussi
des agressions de policiers ces derniers
jours notamment à valenciennes il ya eu
aussi ce face à face assez tendu on va
voir les images à présent entre
gendarmes et personnes
la pénitentiaire c'était dans le val
d'oise une surveillante pénitentiaire
avait été très violemment agressé le 10
décembre dernier et ses collègues donc
ont voulu protester devant leurs centres
pénitenciers d'où ce face à face assez
tendue gilbert collard votre réaction
je trouve tout à fait normal que le
personnel pénitentiaire se mobilisent
quand une surveillante et agressé dans
les conditions que l'on sait
lol quand on voit dans un pays comme le
nôtre deux institutions essentielles à
notre sécurité la gendarmerie et la
pénitentiaire s'affrontaient cela veut
dire qu'il y à un délitement interne de
nos institutions
et quand on voit les gendarmes et les
gardiens de prisons s'affronter c'est la
faillite de l'état c'est un état qui qui
qui qui qui part en bib rinne
alors au lieu de faire la communication
de jouer au baby-foot d'aller se faire
applaudir par les détenus dans dans une
maison d'arrêt le garde des sceaux
ferait mieux de se préoccuper de
renforcer les conditions de sécurité des
membres de l'administration
pénitentiaire qui pour des salaires de
misère font un travail admirable et ô
combien difficile sur le plan
psychologique et physique ça il faut
dire aussi et c'est le signe c'est le
signe que dans ce pays les tensions sont
extrêmes extrême et que on est on est on
est au port au bord d'une explosion de
violences beaucoup plus grave que celle
par sévère que l'on peut voir dans les
dents les images que l'on montre ici ou
là la france est entré en période de
violence qui qui qui annonce des
lendemains où des soir très très
dangereux très grave et ça enfin de ne
pas
voir un mot sur la situation sanitaire
avec cette campagne de vaccination qui
devrait débuter à la fin de l'année
l'europe a avancé d'une semaine pour
tenter de rattraper son retard puisque
on le sait les états unis le canada ou
la russie ont commencé déjà leurs
campagnes de vaccination jour l on
écoute d'abord jean luc mélenchon sur
justement cette question de la
vaccination est votre réaction à suivre
gilbert collard ce vaccin ne me rassure
pas mais je le dis tranquillement je ne
sais pas je ne suis pas médecin je ne
suis pas épidémiologistes je sais juste
qu'un certain nombre de conditions ne me
semble pas respecté vous comprenez cette
inquiétude des français
oui là je partage tout à fait l'opinion
de monsieur mélenchon partout on
applique parfois dur est fait d'une
façon tout à fait excessive le principe
de prudence et là quasiment coco midam
ans avec l'apparition de la pandémie
on voit apparaître un vaccin ce qui est
une rapidité extraordinaire dans
l'histoire des sciences ce vaccin il n'a
pas suffisamment été testés monsieur
vaccin du reste dans une dans une
franchise incroyable lors d'une
conférence de presse la dit art il a dit
on on n'a pas de recul il va agir pour
une période de trois mois
on a en a aucun travaux à ce jour qui
nous permettent d'avoir le recul
suffisant
et puis il n'ya aucune transparence sur
les données financières économiques de
ces négociations
on n'a pas accès au contrat c'est ce que
nous on est député aujourd'hui à
l'assemblée de la transparence vous
pensez que ça va être fait cet après
midi je dois pas je ne crois pas parce
que l'état on dormait dans la plus
grande affaire financière du siècle c
c'est un hold up sur la santé et quand
vous pensez que dans les queues dans les
ehpad
j'ai sur les personnes âgées on a
pratiquement très peu de données sur
l'impact les conséquences du vaccin
c'est quand même particulièrement
préoccupant alors moi je suis pas anti
vaccins que ça soit clair mais restons
prudents et le message des atmosphères
vacciner merci beaucoup et gilbert
collard pardon merci gilbert collard on
n'a plus le temps malheureusement merci
en tout cas d'avoir répondu aujourd'hui
à nos questions en direct sur arte
france